hello and welcome to this video I am
here oh no I am NOT the hero the name so
what do we get here I'm a giant himself
for once playing it to the bogo with my
BD to check yeah both captures are fine
let's see what is coming up with this
night in 94 f five base set up and
there's a set up based on c5 seems like
is going for the f5 set up okay um yeah
and I haven't even played but should be
to him and so maybe start with g5
yeah black yeah Dec normally avoids that
closing closing down the position okay I
have two ideas I can move the night then
play a three or i can play 92 just for
the trade I think I'll do that just form
development reasons not giving up too
much time
I'm not sure maybe he won't even take it
92 have six is certainly possible but i
have f 3 then looks good we're def that
pre move again I'm not in a huge time
Russia anyway so don't need to pre move
yeah in general whites approach is to
just just state that he's got the bishop
am and he can state that very
successfully you can just see it on the
fort and well you just say okay I've got
the two bishops what do what do you have
this is why I closing down the position
is normally am you are not considered to
be that great ham as now the bishop am
in that closed position is actually
pretty good thing is that I have ideas
like therefore even in particular that
leaves black with the inconvenient
choices taking on a foreigner you don't
want to do that playing efore you open
up the bishop and if you're allowed to
take sometimes you have problems with
the f porn so f is the idea I go look au
1 next and then f form that's a strange
move rookie of 6
running straight into my setup Kevin hmm
quite surprised that year that he goes
for that okay um g4 immediately or is
that mistimed hmm g-form nights actually
ok tweenage for I have you met g5
it's a it's actually very bad position
for black I think my cat the diagonal
here is amazingly strong no but should
be six is the concrete idea
yeah I think that was more or less more
or less forced k route 202 how to get
even more more pressure here f5 f6 is
one IDM also double on the G file of
course had the same what's what's best
here i'm shooting for the doubling on
the sea foam I want the g file I'm sorry
ideas root g 3 root g 2 aha ok so he
allows that trade
okay it's difficult not to take this and
now how to continue g5g five hook g2
ma'am it's still fairly solid don't see
him it doesn't break down like
immediately k route 5 blunders into 96
are so not not that one I can do this
however switch attention to the d6 pawn
yeah this is a bit annoying I should
have thought about that move
mmm that was bad shouldn't should have
it there should have prevented
definitely
is certainly no def 118 m three mate
that's uh I sport that game wow what a
shame
let's try it for night H form here time
warning
Queen d70 Scott look everyone that's a
bit of a problem
hmm I have no would move him quite
amazing them
neither three chick I don't see leading
to that much okay now he lets the clock
run down that's good
check is out form maybe this one my dear
three kings you too isn't that
convincing check check check check
check check black forfeits on time yeah
that was probably lucky even even though
I mean the I had a fin de winning
position around here of course but I was
I was really a toilet okay surprisingly
the computer does not stop think white
is better it's kind of strange it's very
strange actually but it's because I
haven't paid attention to some specific
tactics the engine finds this this
amazing ok this is this is a good for
black even ok and here what happens here
I don't get it check check this is
subject amazingly check check ok so we
had this opportunity but now it is much
better right yeah I know what is winning
there was this one moment group g2 c5
and how do I now rook t1 just doing this
but I don't think this the skin can be
can be bad having the real issue was
that yeah absolutely should not play
this allowing g5 that's just not a good
idea 25 is pretty good yam first pinning
here and just keeping complete control
over this this is just much much better
piece on c3 compared to the night and
he's got the Fargo structure it was a
bad mistake allowing this the engine
still gives queen d 6 is clearly better
for me interestingly enough
yeah Queen f7 is a move that I had not
evaluated correctly now black gets
excellent and excellent play there and
reg phone Teague's check ya hear Black
is winning probably aunt hit head stuff
yeah he is a made Queen you have made
King uh what did he do actually okay
well this is the maid check yep pretty
clear I have to take now and that's it's
a story to be a maid check check yeah it
here he has to take you to and win check
this is losing after who gave two
amazingly enough check check that's very
shaky yeah I was very lucky in should
have should we lost that one even though
we'll ask for the fantastic position
before but still that was mate ok oh
thanks for watching